how you doing Mike I'm doing very very
fair budget so I'm giving you the floor
about your comments and Collins responds
well in terms of the response I
understand that you know Colin may have
seen my comments and just like everybody
else I think that was kind of taken out
of context with what I truly meant was
in those terms of image and I've been
down that road before I you know even
though Colin and I have two different
issues that we had to deal with at some
point and my career in his is right now
he didn't commit a crime he didn't do
anything wrong you know I was involved
in something totally different so the
only thing I could reflect on was my
past experiences and how I was able to
help myself through the eyes of a lot of
people and just a lot of help you know
from other individuals white black and
indifferent it was not the past Colin I
apologize for that because I'm
responsible for everything for
everything that comes out of my mouth
and the only reason I stated what our
state is because I was looking at a
screen shot of him as they were showing
highlights and as we was talking about
the topic and you know even though I'm
not a Jim and I don't know why Colin is
not on the team right now I really don't
know I'm trying to find reasons to help
him and you know that's the only thing I
could think about at the time but in
every other any of you I ever did I
always supported Colin I always talked
about him having the opportunity at some
point in the right situation the right
system you know so I've always been very
supportive but at that point in time I
was just only going off without what I
had seen so that was the first thing
that popped in my mind I maybe didn't
convey right but it wasn't with cruel
intentions to hurt Colin or disrespect
anybody out there who may have viewed it
different so were you ever given that
advice the one that you just imparted to
come yeah when I was going through you
know my trials and tribulations yes you
know somebody did sit me down and say I
think you need to you know cut your
brains off and I have brains at the time
or not I like
the more having them and I thought it
was cool but you know at the end of the
day I said that I thought about and I
was like you know what if this is gonna
fit me they'll help me in terms of you
know night with a prison sentence so
getting me out of trouble if they can
just help me to start to conform and you
know not you know try to do anything
anybody else want me to go change for
the better myself and I had a tons of
people looking up to me and you know
being a role model I felt like I was
setting an example and just trying to
lead in that regard so you know I took
the advice and I did it it didn't change
anything you know I still you know went
through hardships but for me personally
I just felt better you know in terms of
my parents mike vick joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show look Mike I've heard
Dion give that advice to up-and-coming
prospects at the combine burgeoning
stars in the NFL who had cornrows or who
had braids as you said or long hair and
and and Dion's told him cut your hair
because corporate America wants you to
look a certain way and you should
succeed to the best you can in the
National Football League and in the 90s
and the National Football League I think
in all workplaces you everybody has to
you know look presentable I think if you
want to you know move up the ranks if
you want to you know you know just you
know it's part father's personal
apprentice just not you know disrespect
anyone but look respectable and that has
nothing to do with the reason why Colin
is not playing has nothing to do like
people may lose their job or not get a
job with maybe it does but you know at
the end of the day I think it was just
something that um you know I said
because I was searching for answers and
wanted to really want to help this kid
this guy you know I won't continue to
call him a kid because I know is
demeaning but you know I look at
Kaepernick as a little brother and you
know I was an advocate for him with Nike
you know over the years you know when he
first got his deal with them and you
know I've always been you know a marvel
of his game and how hard he worked
over the years so I would never do
anything to try to hurt him look as a
detriment you know to his career we want
to see him succeed I want to see them
back in NFL but that's not my you know
call it to me well in terms of the what
what what the difference I guess between
what Dion tells a prospect and what
people may have perceived or perceiving
what you said to Kaepernick is that his
look if he changes his look than a team
that is concerned about his message
might be less so because of how he looks
and and thus it denigrates in a way what
Kaepernick is saying or is trying to get
out there like you understand and I
think in terms of Kaepernick suggestion
what he did the nail I mean we we
understood it and you know a lot of
people respected it I respected what he
was doing you know I take my hat off to
him for standing up but I think it could
have if he would have you know like I
said in my message maybe if he was
clean-cut and doing it then maybe it
looked different that's all I was trying
to say I wasn't trying to say anything
to hurt the guy I'd want to help him and
that's what it was the first thing that
came to my mind so you know like I told
him I'm sorry for saying it but in terms
of his message that's not me and I don't
I won't condone in it and I won't
continue to take this any further than
what it is because it's not my issue
rich and every time I turn around people
accidentally about him and I've always
supported him and you know I was
encouraged people to go listen to all my
previous interviews and just noted but
I'm a havoc I'm an advocate in terms of
calling company you know getting a job
an opportunity to play and I've always
said it just has to be the right
situation I still will stand by what I
said in terms of productivity you know
that it hasn't been up to par over the
last couple years and I truly believe
did that have something you know to do
with him not being fired always said I
think he will be signed
some point in the right situation unless
there's prey to that happens but as far
as what people are saying and thinking
starts I'm Eli I'm responsible for
everything that comes out of my mouth
but people know my integrity and know
that I was just trying to help him and I
leave it at that couple of more minutes
with you Mike if you don't indulge so do
you think that if he cutters here he
would be apt to be signed by an NFL a
lot of other Amish that will make a
difference as of right now I think you
know in terms of general managers and
wanting to bring a man it would have to
be the correct situation for him to come
in and play whether he had braiser not
if the team needs them if he has a offer
on the team needs him he will get signed
but from a personal image standpoint I
remember him when he first came out and
you know his look and I was just saying
to myself you know every scholar Colin
goes back to that look then you know
it's just you know it just made me help
them in a sense you know wait people you
know and Isaac the general managers
maybe but that was that won't be the
reason his reason for him being signed
would be because of what he brings to
the table and that's the skills that
they're getting some sometimes can be
unmatched and he's still a young player
so he has a lot of potential and it
still spent and said and I see him on
the team right now and I feel for the
guy but I really want talk to him
personally so I can you know understand
what you know where his mind is if
there's a right now and be able to
convey his message to the world because
we had we haven't heard from we haven't
seen them as far as I know I don't even
I don't know if he has a you know boy
heading out you know if he has waves if
he still has an afro I don't know I was
just going to what I figured on TV yeah
I was wrong it never got I said I said
have you tried to reach out to him Mike
my restocks from this morning I called
him insects in this morning and and you
know he hasn't gotten back with me yet
but I'm pretty sure he will I we
understand it that I'm I'm in this
corner okay and if you don't mind what
what what do you plan to tell him can
you can you lay that out just in case
you don't get back tomorrow for you know
compounded you know what I don't think
is a
but just an issue that he's dealing with
as of right now and let him know that
that you know as a as a friend
and I have the utmost respect for him
and would he stand for and in any way
shape or form I wouldn't try to negate
anything that he's done you know in
terms of his success in his beliefs and
I won't have to continue to believe in
what he believed in and continue to push
hard and know that everything that's
going to work out for him at some point
and know that I'm not against them and I
never will be against them
Mike appreciate appreciate the time
thanks for calling
all right favorite you go that's uh Mike
Vick on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slow-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about